[Music]
hey you guys welcome to tomes of terror
my little humble book review show
the book that we have this week this is
kind of like a weird i want to say it's
like a wild card but it's kind of like a
thing where
this is a book
that i just bought it on a whim like a
really long time ago remember back i
don't know if they if they still have
this but you know like barnes and noble
maybe like books a million and stuff
like that like usually in the front of
the store they'd have all of these kind
of shelves and they had a lot of hard
covers and stuff like that that were
usually like really really cheap they'd
be like you know five bucks or something
like that because sometimes it'd be
books that it subsequently come out of
paperback and they were trying to like
get rid of all their uh you know of all
their stock of the hardcovers i don't
know if that was the case with this one
but this was just a book that i just
kind of saw at random i'd never heard of
the author i'd never heard anybody talk
about it but i just kind of liked the
cover and i was kind of like because the
cover uh which this is not the same
cover that the paperback has so uh you
know so i might not have even picked it
up otherwise but see the cover here it's
called enamorata by the way by joseph
gangemi i hope i'm pronouncing that
right sorry if i'm not uh joseph but see
look it's kind of like looks very like
ooh spiritualism with like the seance
and stuff and uh i don't know if you
guys know but i love [ __ ] about
seances and spiritualism and stuff like
from that time period like i just really
really like stories about that so i
picked it up and i read like the inside
blurb and i was like oh man that sounds
pretty good so i just like picked it up
i think it was like i said i think it
was like 4.99 or something like that and
this was like years and years ago
because this book came out
in
2004 which i don't know i don't remember
how old it was when i first bought it i
probably bought it in like [ __ ]
i don't know 2008 something like that
maybe even earlier i don't remember but
uh but yeah so i read it
and i really really liked it at the time
and then you know stuck it back on my
shelves as i as i do with all of the
books that i buy
and then while i was kind of casting
about for you know another book to do
like for this series
um i still had a couple that i had
bought that i needed to get to like to
read and you know eventually like but
i'm getting through like the pile that i
bought which is good
i think i only have one or two left
but the thing about it was that i was
like well after that i might go to like
kindle unlimited i'll go to like ebook
and stuff like that until i can afford
to buy another pile of books but when i
was looking through my shelves i was
like you know i have a bunch of books
here that i wouldn't actually mind
rereading and then i could like review
them for the show and enemarata was one
of them because i was kind of like i was
going through the shelves and i was kind
of like man i remember that being really
good let me read it again and you know
see if it holds up and if it's holds up
then i'm going to review it for the show
because i feel like maybe maybe she gets
a little bit more attention i don't know
like i feel like this author has not
written much more than this like i think
he's written a couple more books but not
much this was actually his first novel
when i looked to this up on goodreads
there's only three pages of reviews
which for good reads that's like hardly
anything
so
i don't know so i may be like one of the
few people that read this i'm not really
sure but uh which is a shame because
this book is really really good and
honestly i remember liking it like when
i first read it back in the 2000s or
whatever
but rereading it
i i was like man i forgot how [ __ ]
good this book is it's just like so it's
not
it's not a straight up horror novel it's
kind of more like a spiritualist ghost
story-ish mystery and it also has like a
little bit of a romance thing going on
but not in a blood like not a not in
that kind of way because i don't like
that [ __ ] either um so there is kind of
like a sort of love story sort of but
that's not really the main part of the
plot now interestingly one thing that i
guess i had forgotten
in the years since i had first read this
book was that this book is actually
based on it's fictionalized everyone's
names are changed and stuff and a lot of
details are changed too but this is
actually based on on real uh events
so what happens in this book it's set in
1923.
and uh there's the guy the main guy who
you we see everything's it's in the
first person his name is martin finch
and he's actually a grad student at
harvard
and he gets called in by this guy
mclaughlin who's like the head of uh you
know whatever department
that he's studying in
and uh this mclaughlin guy is also the
head of the local like society for
psychical research chapter
and the they work for he's working for
scientific american now scientific
american and this is true
in the 1920s when spiritualism was all
the rage
a scientific american offered 5 000
in 1920s money i don't even know how
that's i mean that's got to be like
that's a astronomical sum so i'm like
that's still kind of a lot of money
nowadays so in 1920s i can't imagine
like how much [ __ ] that must be like a
million bucks or something
but uh so yes they were offering five
thousand dollars to anyone who could
demonstrate actual genuine psychic
ability uh in usually like in a seance
type of setting or like while this
investigating committee was there and
like i said that was a real uh that was
a real thing that was a real thing that
they offered and there was a committee
that would go around to seances and go
around and visit different psychics and
stuff uh psychics who were trying to get
the prize you know what i mean because
obviously five thousand dollars so
they're going to get all kind of people
like coming in there now in real life uh
one of the guys that was on the
committee was harry houdini um he's not
really a character in this book he does
he is mentioned a couple of times like
he is you know there like in this
universe but he's um not like on the
committee like he was in real life
so like i said this is it's based a lot
on real [ __ ] but he changed a lot of
stuff around but when i was reading some
of like the wikipedia entries about some
of the real [ __ ] that happened in here
um he didn't change as much as i thought
that that he might have
but so martin finch he is uh like i said
a grad student now what ends up
happening is that mclaughlin uh they're
supposed to go and investigate
this uh supposed psychic medium whose
name is mina crawley
now this woman was suggested to them by
arthur conan doyle uh you know who's
also like i said not a character in the
book but he is brought up in the book's
universe and him saying and arthur conan
doyle uh saying you know she we think
she's the real thing she's the one that
might get the prize and everything like
that now unlike most of the other
psychics
uh who
actually petitioned scientific american
hey come see my magical psychic powers
so i can win five thousand dollars um
she didn't actually want to do it so the
committee actually went to her and like
wrote her a letter because she had been
recommended by sir arthur conan doyle
and uh you know want did you know do you
want us to investigate you can get the
prize money and everything like that and
for a long time she didn't want to do it
like she refused she's like i don't need
the money and uh you know she's like i
don't really want to you know go into
that kind of scrutiny or anything like
that but they finally convinced her to
do it now what ends up happening is that
mclaughlin who's supposed to be like the
head of the committee for the scientific
uh american investigation team he ends
up like slipping on some ice or
something like busting his hip or
whatever so he ends up sending martin
finch in his place like the grad student
and uh one of the things that martin
finch is good at
is that he's really good at kind of
building things like he has kind of like
an engineering type of mind he's good at
kind of engineering these little things
that will that will make it apparent
like if psychics are faking you know
what i mean like he's really good at
kind of like building like for this one
like at the beginning of the book like
he kind of builds this one thing that
kind of goes under the floorboard so
they can tell like if the psychic gets
up or something like that so he makes
kind of all these little contraptions uh
that are meant to kind of catch all
these psychics out like when they're at
the seances
so he gets sent along in his place and
uh there's four other dudes uh three or
four other dudes on the committee uh all
of whom are kind of pissed that this
young upstart who's only 24 i think uh
is gonna be
there on mclaughlin's behalf because
mclaughlin was supposed to be kind of
the head of the thing and now this
little this young whippersnapper is
there in their place and it it kind of
seems like too that so there's all these
kind of like
you know
inter academia kind of uh infighting and
they just don't want to listen to him
because they think he's just like wet
behind the ears and there's all this
other kind of stuff it's like oh
mclaughlin company just sent you instead
and we're not gonna like listen to you
or respect you or anything like that
but when they get to uh they go to
philadelphia which is where uh mina
crawley lives with her husband who is an
uh uh he's an obstetrician like a
surgeon
and uh so they go there and what ends up
happening is that the [ __ ]
other members of the committee
they got there before martin finch did
and basically got their own rooms and
said that that there was only three of
them so when he goes there to check into
the hotel that he's supposed to check
into there's like oh sorry no room for
you i don't know how that could have
happened you know it'd be like very very
[ __ ]
so uh being kind of ballsy he's like
well you know what um i'm gonna go over
to
mina crawley's house like her and her
husband's house and since we're gonna be
over there anyway like investigating
them and maybe i could crash over there
so he does that and it turns out that
they're really uh accommodating and very
welcoming and stuff like that now as the
book goes on
uh some complications arise
in the sense that there's kind of a
thing where martin finch
sort of starts to fall for mina crawley
which kind of starts to cloud his
objectivity because he doesn't really
want
to hurt her feelings by saying that he
thinks she's a fake
but then as the as it goes on and they
have more and more seances and he kind
of devises different things to like see
if she's faking and so it seems like she
might be faking some stuff but then
there's some other stuff that doesn't
seem like she's faking so it's just all
very kind of like ambiguous now what it
is is that when she uh she when she's at
the sands she said she never used to
have psychic powers before
but suddenly she had like some kind of
tragedy happen like a year prior and
then all of a sudden she kind of
discovered this latent psychic ability
and what she does is that she goes she
has the seance in the dark and
everything and then she has a spirit
control who uh this dude named walter
who you find out about halfway through
the book was actually her brother
so
apparently her brother has died and is
now serving as a spirit control and is
uh kind of like angry like he's an angry
kind of ghost
during some of the seances there's kind
of [ __ ] like you know pianos banging the
keys of the piano banging downstairs
like he knocks [ __ ] over like the china
cabinet and everything like that so as
it goes on like they're trying to like
the investigating team
have all uh are all kind of like charmed
by mina crowley because she's just like
such a lovely person not just like a
physically you know lovely person but
she's also like you know
you know she's just like a really nice
person and so they really feel really
bad
of you know having to do things like oh
we have to tie her ankles to the chair
so she can't move her feet and we have
to do this on the other thing and all
these kind of protocols that they have
to come up with to make sure that she's
not faking and uh so as it goes on they
all kind of become charmed by her and
they don't really want to do that so
there's all this kind of like you know
things with the objectivity and there's
a thing too where martin finch who
essentially falls in love with her but
is the most skeptical and is the most
suspicious that there's something weird
going on uh whereas the other three guys
are just kind of like [ __ ] it we just
you know she's she's real we'll give her
the prize and they just kind of wanted
to go to philadelphia and
and eat on the scientific americans
expense account and you know yeah we're
going to give somebody the money and
then we're going to publish this big
article about it and it'll sell all
these copies and we'll get you know
promotions and all this other kind of
[ __ ] so they're not real rigorous uh
about you know trying to like disprove
her actual psychic ability so there's
like a lot of so there's like a lot of
conflict like between the group and
everything like that and like i said
there's also a lot of conflict in the
household because he is very clearly
falling for mina she seems to be falling
for him as well but then there's like
some really weird [ __ ] going on with
her and her husband
and it's just it's just really weird
like her husband who's like i said a
surgeon like he'll do weird [ __ ] like
he's kind of like over shares like too
much information and it's almost kind of
like he's encouraging
something to happen between mina and
martin like he'll be like oh well you
know she's after the seance she's really
tired i have to go to work and do these
surgeries so why don't you stay in the
house and like look after her for me and
like [ __ ] like that there's like all
this kind of weird [ __ ] going on and
then there's stuff like they put him in
a room like in a guest room that's like
butts up to their bedroom so it's like
sometimes he thinks he can hear them
having sex so there's like really weird
[ __ ] going on so there's all kind of
weird [ __ ] going on in there when they
do the seances and walter the spirit
control starts talking you know there's
this whole thing about him and uh the
the doctor dr crawley like not getting
along and uh you know so they're kind of
like coming up with all these uh insults
toward each other and all this other
stuff so you're not entirely sure
like what the end like you don't know if
walter is really a ghost
or if
she's pulling some kind of trick if her
and the husband are both pulling some
kind of trick if there's somebody else
that's in on it uh so martin like i said
is kind of like the whole thing is
almost kind of like you know it's kind
of like a detective like a mystery
because he's kind of bound and
determined even though he's fallen in
love with her and doesn't want to hurt
her feelings by saying she's a fake
because she does genuinely seem to
believe that she has psychic abilities
but he really wants to get to the bottom
of does she really have psychic
abilities or is there something like a
lot more complicated going on because
there's all this kind of like sketchy
[ __ ] going on around this kind of thing
so as i mentioned uh you know this is
actually based loosely on real events so
the scientific american thing uh you
know where they went and investigated
psychics and everything with harry
houdini that really did happen uh they
were actually offering five thousand
dollars mina crawley in this book uh is
actually based on mina crandon uh who
they called marjorie uh very very famous
in spiritualist parapsychology circles
she actually also claimed to have a
spirit control that was named walter
that i believe was her dead brother and
uh interestingly i was reading her
wikipedia page go look up mina crandon
uh you know so like i said in paranormal
circles very very well-known uh spirit
medium and she was investigated multiple
times uh she actually allegedly that
they know of did actually have an affair
with at least one of the investigating
committee uh you know again kind of
getting in with their objectivity and
everything like that so a lot of the
[ __ ] that he's talking about like in
this book it is fictionalized ever like
everyone's names are names are changed
and some of the personalities are kind
of switched around
but a surprising amount of the story in
this is based on
the real story of mina crandon like or
marjorie
she her husband was also uh you know a
surgeon so it's like there was just all
this kind of stuff going on and that's
all the backbiting and fighting like
with the investigation community
committee like some of them wanting to
like say you know certify her as real
and the other one's thinking she was
faking and there's all this other kind
of stuff so it's really kind of a
fascinating i mean what a what a great
uh thing to like base a story on and
like i said it was just i really really
liked this a lot like i said it's not a
horror novel necessarily it's more like
a mystery but if you really like and and
the period detail in this like for you
know all the stuff from like the 1920s
is really really good like he doesn't
dump you over the head like it's not
like a big exposition dump it's like oh
and then there's not pages and pages of
like exposition to describing things
because everything's from martin finch's
point of view you know on the
investigation committee like it's in
first person
so you know he did they just mentioned
things he just mentions things like in
passing like different kinds of cars
like different kinds of products that
were available time so it's like really
really cool it really gives you
a sense of place and it really gives you
a sense of place of like philadelphia
which is where the author is uh from i
don't think he's from there originally i
think he's from delaware but he moved to
philadelphia and he lived there when he
wrote this so he kind of so philadelphia
in the 1920s almost becomes kind of like
a character in itself which is kind of
neat but if you're really really into
seances which i love i love anything
about that like i said that's an
immediately like why i picked this book
up because like i saw like the seance
kind of thing with you know and i love
all that spiritualist kind of theme uh
for for a story and i'm really glad i
picked this one up i had forgotten too
how
funny this book is not like
not like over the top funny like you
know it's not like that it's just kind
of like just the the observations that
the main character makes uh and the
turns of phrases are just like very very
witty and like very very amusing to me
but uh yeah and it's also like a super
fast
read i mean i cuz actually i kind of got
ahead on my book reviews because
you know when i did the amulet last week
and that took me like almost no time at
all to read because that was such a good
time and then this one i kind of started
it and then like i didn't want to put it
down like i seriously i read it like in
two sittings and i was like man i forgot
like how good this was like how good the
mystery is um you know how it kind of
like strings you along and you're just
like what the [ __ ] is going on with this
lady it's like is she really is she
crazy is is is she really a psychic is
she really channeling this ghost it's
like you know or is there some other
kind of [ __ ] going on is she being
hypnotized it's like there's all kind of
different possibilities and it's just
like really really intriguing but yeah
it's just when i read all the reviews on
goodreads most of them seemed kind of
like there were some that like really
really loved it because i really loved
this book i thought it was and i
actually i enjoyed it much more this
time than i did the first time i read it
because i had forgotten like how
well-written it was how
kind of riley amusing it was uh how
fast-paced it is and just kind of like
the whole
spiritualist vibe like in the whole like
i said that's really evocative of 1920s
philadelphia and evocative of the whole
like kind of spiritualist uh movement
and i really really liked the way that
was conveyed like it just kind of kept
me it's just really it's really
immersive and i was really into it um it
seemed like a lot of the reviews that
were mostly like were like three stars
it's like oh this is okay but i don't
know if people were like expecting
more of a straight-up ghost story or
more of a straight-up horror story like
i said this is more like it's kind of
like a ghost story but it's more like a
mystery so you know so if you are into
that kind of stuff because like i said i
like i like all that kind of stuff like
seances debunking seances like all this
[ __ ] about houdini and everything like
that i find that [ __ ] really fascinating
you know all this stuff about arthur
conan doyle and
his kind of like
forays into spiritualism i'm really
fascinated by that kind of stuff so if
you like that kind of stuff um this is a
really really good fictionalized account
even though a lot of it uh is based on
real stuff that happened like right
around that time but like i said it's
really well written um i don't think
this guy has written that many more
books but
now that i've reread this one and
enjoyed it so much i was kind of like
well maybe i should go look for some of
his other books too because maybe some
other ones because like i said this
subject matter is like right up my alley
so there you go and i feel like it
doesn't it hasn't really got a lot of
reviews it hasn't really got a lot of
attention
and somebody on goodreads though said
this one now i don't know if this is
true or not because it's just the only
source for it that i saw was like one
person on goodreads said that johnny
depp
had purchased the rights to this book in
2006 with the hopes of making it into a
movie but obviously that never happened
i don't not that i know of i don't know
if that's true or not but it was like
actually i think this would make kind of
a cool ass movie now that i'm thinking
about it i don't know i just think it
would but like i said that's that's me i
like that kind of i like that kind of
1920 setting i like the spiritualist
setting so if you
if that sounds like something that you
would uh really be into and like i said
it's more of a mystery um then
definitely check this one out uh as i
said this i really like this cover
actually and this is what first
attracted me to it's very very striking
uh i think the paperback actually just
has i think it's like black or blue with
like a bird on it because martin finch
and and actually i think the real guy
that he's supposed to be was actually
named malcolm bird and i think if i'm
remembering it correctly that in the
book like in the universe of the book
martin finch they write an article about
the
investigation and they give him the
pseudonym martin bird even though like i
said in real life his real name was bart
bird so or uh yeah malcolm bird so i
think if i remember remembering that
correctly but yeah seriously check this
book out it's really really fun it's
really really good and it's you know it
kind of keeps you guessing like all the
way to the end and it leaves some things
like ambiguous enough that you can kind
of like fill in a lot of your own blanks
which i thought was kind of good too so
uh so yeah so check it out if you've
read it on the off chance because like i
said i don't really hear that many
people talking about it but if you have
read it let me know what you thought
about it in the comments and that'll do
it for this tomes of terror and i will
see you guys on the next one bye